as she was saying the [ __ ] [ __ ] smoke
got up in her [ __ ] nasal passage
open the garage door
aren't you supposed to got
not from smoking you choking the way we
are there she's still she's still human
bro okay
[Music]
all right everybody familiar with KSI
yeah yeah okay recently came out and no
came out the closet noticing he's
fighting someone
yeah he is fighting somebody
um but she came out talking about uh
even though he has over 10 million
followers on tick tock
guess how much money he's made from the
platform two thousand dollars that
sounds about right that sounds about
right three thousand pounds oh [ __ ] oh
yeah yeah Tick Tock doesn't pay dude but
what about brand deals and stuff oh
that's I'm guessing that's like not
counted you know what I mean why what's
the rationale for tick tock even paying
you is it do they run ads on Tick Tock
they they do but it's not it's not the
same [ __ ] yeah they just give the
Chinese Communist party uh some data
about Americans that's all it is that's
payment enough yeah but if you go
incognito mode they can't see it they
can't see it thank God for Incognito
they don't have incognito mode in China
it's like they're the CIA is watching
you with headphones on you go Incognito
we lost them
the whole of the van we can't get them
anymore every single person is being
listened to by a single CIA agent with
headphones ah he went Incognito and then
you go you come back and they're like
Jesus Christ is Jason Bourne this guy's
a professional he's sure he did
Madagascar
I like how he's listening to the website
too because it's Incognito yeah what
videos is he watching text-to-speech
yeah
so yeah you guys are right uh Tick Tock
doesn't really pay out that much and you
know he continues to say afterwards that
creators will slowly move to YouTube to
make the real money that's eventually I
mean that's what happened to all the
vine people that's what Mr B said too
yeah it is but or if people create
products they can sell it on their Tick
Tock I think that's what people do right
like Tick Tock live is huge for some of
us Fitness friends that are on Tick Tock
it's like a whole new generation of like
Fitness like influencers man some of
these guys are pulling in big dollars
even though they'll make money on Tick
Tock the amount they can drive to their
website is crazy like the algorithms
they're using Tick Tock as like the the
just the just the audience Builder and
it can grow much faster than any other
platform oh yeah that's true that's how
you use it right it begs to ask the
question why we're not doing [ __ ] we are
on Tick Tock selling stuff and making
money yeah Bart you should have like
some shitty AB swing or something like
that oh yeah I suck at this shitty AB
swing yeah dude like these reports like
this will get your abs going like my abs
and then it's like some [ __ ] metal
Contraption where you just have to do
sit-ups on top of the metal Contraption
which my mom bought every [ __ ] one of
those back in the day see everyone all
you got to do is repurpose something
that already exists and put barbell like
a [ __ ] dildo medicine ball right yeah
and then right barbell Brigade and then
you [ __ ] have you you just you just
ride that [ __ ] like that and be
like get better squats and [ __ ] yeah and
[ __ ] it's handy you brilliant ideas
what a piece of [ __ ] that you couldn't
he couldn't type that he didn't write
anything I saw him dude that was
[ __ ] I'm a good live shot I have my
keyboard memory we literally have people
watching you live yeah
dude how come I never I'm never watching
YouTube but I see Bart and he's like
he's like hey you want to know a secret
that the fitness experts are keeping
Bark's red
you know the liver King was finally
outed for for his steroid use people are
pissed he's using ten thousand dollars
worth of oh no he was on steroids you
guys thought he's eating mouse livers I
thought he got that rip from eating
[ __ ] yeah Pig ear all day so he was
just hiding people confront him about
taking steps no so they leaked an email
that he was talking with this [ __ ]
dealer his his steroid plug his plug and
then they just listed out like a
confirmation nation of what he wanted to
buy and then that email got did we need
this wasn't he roid raging on every
podcast yeah people I don't know why
people are so like [ __ ] like oh we
got him do you think I know it's like
come on you guys like take your hat off
oh see your hair and he's like hey
what'd you say about my wife
[ __ ] I [ __ ] kill you but
we're like oh yeah
yeah we really need that though yeah
dude and guess what he's still gonna
sell everything like hotcakes his [ __ ]
is probably that's what mind blowing
because I'm like duh he's on steroids
you think he got that from [ __ ] elk
balls and [ __ ] Bart didn't think so He
barked in the human stairs
vegetarian
he was like that's the only natural
[ __ ] out there Bart's on
steroids
honestly every day I text a steroid
expert about steroids because I really
really should I do it yeah pull the
trigger you pull the trigger why haven't
you put the steroid expert here instead
of your Gardener would you want to I'll
bring a steroids bro can we get Dr Mike
here it probably would be down dude we
would have so much fun with Dr Mike he's
so cool yeah
a gardener too though yeah well can we
talk to the [ __ ] time traveler lady
finally now he won't even he won't even
commit to that he instantly commits the
steroid guy because it personally
interests him yeah it's because he's
more we want to talk to Time Travelers I
don't have a time travel to connect your
mom knows a time traveler no I know a
[ __ ] she built a time machine air herb
Grabber
thin air
okay this is not how he marketed it no
it's not he said last time they had a
time machine he talks to spirits and she
she talks to spirits and she gets in a
[ __ ] capsule she gets she grabs
medicine from thin air that's what she
does let's talk to her I need some
medicine right now what does that look
like so when I was uh I injured my
forearm
um my junior year from wrestling and
then my mom is like we're not gonna go
to a fun chiropractor or physical
therapist or whatever the normal [ __ ] is
we're gonna go see this lady we're gonna
go see a Time trap yeah all right fine
so what's crazy is my parents were
divorced at the time and so I was living
with my dad see he's a Time him and so
okay
while I was living there
so like I'm very very suspicious of
stuff and
um because you know a lot of magicians
still pre-set up the place maybe a week
before before they show up right so of
course they can pull all these [ __ ]
tricks yeah so my mom brings this lady
in and she was like this lady well you
shouldn't care anything I mean all right
whatever so I'm sitting there
and then she goes okay let me see her
forearm she touches it and she goes go
boil some hot water I'm like all right
so I go boil some hot water and I have
it on the table and she starts [ __ ]
speaking in [ __ ] tongues or whatever
the [ __ ] do you think when you went to
go bullhall or that's when she prepped
the powder
I don't know it could be but she starts
going like this right like her like she
has her sleeves [ __ ] rolled up to her
elbows and her hands are just in front
of my face like this just saying [ __ ]
like this and then she starts going
whatever and then she goes hold out your
hand and hold out my hand and literally
from her fingers a [ __ ] mound of
powder she had a fake thumb dude
I'm still I'm still suspicious to say a
mound of powder amount of powder she's
gonna bump real quick yeah and then I
was like what the [ __ ] and then I boiled
it I drank it I don't know if it's
Placebo I did heal but I still don't
believe her because I'm like this
doesn't make physical sense so she gets
so she gave you opium she put it in
water dude and Ashley was doing it the
whole room filled with some herbal smell
the whole room filled with it she
prepared when you went to go boil water
girl what do you mean what do you mean
you don't believe her dude the [ __ ] in
your hand smelled like herbals yeah the
whole the whole room and the powder it
all smells like Earth's ginseng so yeah
she just poured some marbles in your
hand maybe I don't know where the [ __ ]
she got it from maybe a fake thumb or
whatever her tricks are and then she had
fun she had her sleeves down like that
so it was like this this thing and I
believe nobody so I'm like man this
[ __ ] [ __ ] lie my mom gonna go like
this how you don't believe anybody but
she she used a 12 magic kit on you yeah
she put a red ball from here
Bart's like she had this ball and it
turned into three balls I don't know you
guys explained that [ __ ] to me she had a
scarf that she stepped it in her head
she started doing the cards thing
so those are the type of people my mom
knows okay my mom knows he's [ __ ]
weird [ __ ] sounds legit dude yeah let's
talk to her please but I can't yeah I'm
not she's not accessible to her it's so
weird because my mom's homie my mom's
like why are you bring six dudes to her
house for to [ __ ] have her do magic
tricks yeah
that sounds incredible it's like we're
mocking her she's gonna hurt her
feelings We're Not Gonna mock her I
won't even dress like this oh whoa wait
that's not that's not really useful
the Rebrand man come on you won't laugh
until after imagine you don't want to
kill it yeah what if we did go to mocker
and we all got [ __ ] cured of all the
My psoriasis goes away and [ __ ] and
we're just sitting right now I'll be her
number one proponent dude if she could
pick if she could fix our [ __ ] that we
have issues if I come out of there with
like dandruff like hair going all the
way down to my back like I'm a horse
like I'm a horse chick yeah yeah yeah I
looked down my penis is like four inches
now so whoa let's go dang doubled inside
that's a win that's [ __ ] 100x that
would be crazy if we were just [ __ ]
around and it ended up being like that
that would be really cool what would
everybody want what would everybody want
cured by dust I go hair and of course I
go in front of my hair don't worry about
it you guys could probably go one by one
I probably hooked that up I don't know
about six people showing a better place
you gotta stop making the rules man you
can't bring it out here you can't make
the rules she can come to us it's hard
to balance a X-Men and also mom's friend
component you know so I can't treat it
like a spectacle because she's my mom
we're not gonna treat her like a
spectator
you have no respect for us I'll pretend
like I don't even know she has a time
machine yeah
I know you got it I'm not even gonna
call her HG Wing I'm good with old Asian
ladies are you yeah all right I'll hook
you guys up first and see how it goes we
should just go and say we have a group
ailment that we need help with our
channel is dying yeah boom well that's a
good one our Channel's dying so what's
dying our Channel I'll tell you
something that is funny so when my dad
passed away at my mom's house my uh my
mom hired her to do a ceremony there and
then so of course she's gonna [ __ ] do
her [ __ ] like talking to the spirits
and [ __ ] yeah and then so she created
this big ass bonfire in the middle of
the garage to burn like some of my dad's
belongings and [ __ ] yeah as she was
saying the [ __ ] [ __ ] smoke got up in
her [ __ ] nasal passage
open the garage door foreign
[Laughter]
Martin disapproves can you legally do a
bonfire in a garage hell yeah I don't
think how did you guys turn it off you
put water on it no if you can't so her
rules are you can't touch it like you
have to let the fire burn out even if
the house is on fire
the burnouts with going through the
spirit world he's just a [ __ ] pyro
dude
this is like with 13 year old kids in my
neighborhood
doing the [ __ ] Aqua Net
you have to let it burn out and then
she's sitting like yeah you gotta burn
the spirits yeah
was there something of your dads that
you would have liked and then she just
Chucks him on the [ __ ] fire
now it's all like flammable stuff like
shirts and pants and socks and [ __ ] damn
dude she had to burn this and you guys
[ __ ] hot
boxed the garage yeah that was her idea
when my mom wanted it I'm like it's your
house I guess there wasn't a point where
you were like we're doing a closed
garage bonfire something Seance it's I
don't know it's it's my mom you know
she's already I've already been
accustomed to over 30 years of
craziness that it's just like this is
one of our wise ideas so
[ __ ] it let it burn right yeah you know
you can't really can't knock it bro yeah
until you try it like Geo just sent me
it so she's my Mom's hanging out our
house right now she just sent me a video
this morning like there's this [ __ ]
what's that thing that's like on a cable
when you swing oh the zip line zip line
there's a [ __ ] kid like a zip line
for kids at the park and my mom sends me
a video I mean my Jill said maybe my mom
on it you know that's just how she is
like there's no 70 year old lady that's
gonna ride it but my mom will that's
tight oh yeah that and closed garage
bonfire same same basket that's the no
that was like years of Bart telling us
his mom's so crazy and she's just in a
park like dancing like this and it's
like yeah no she's not yeah but this
[ __ ] is [ __ ] crazy spirit world mom
time traveling friends yeah bonfires and
close faces hey I'm not I'm not gonna
poo pooed anymore though you know I'm
not gonna poop
I don't think so funny dude it's wild
that he knows somebody who time travel
but just keeps going I don't have that I
don't know what that is he's the one
that said time traveling
[Music]